[Music]
if you're a fan of role-playing games
you've probably played one Chris Avalon
has worked on there's something unique
about each of them whether it's the deep
and mature a narrative of clean scape
torment the way Knights of the Old
Republic to deconstructs the light side
and dark side morality of Star Wars or
the fact that South Park the stick of
truth was actually a really good South
Park game now Avalon is working with in
exile entertainment on wasteland 2 it's
the sequel to the original
post-apocalyptic RPG which later
inspired the Fallout series a three
million dollar Kickstarter campaign
means the team can bring back wasteland
one's old-school role-playing with a
modern presentation but what does it
actually mean to write and design for
the sequel to a 16 year old game
according to Avalon it's all about
making the story more reactive I think
what makes wasteland 2 different than
other RPGs I've worked on is a sheer
amount of reactivity chains because that
was such a big part at wasteland one a
lot of the reactivity chains for
wasteland to have at least three steps
when other RPGs I think there might have
been one period of reactivity to it or
like one choke point where someone
reacts to it but but in wasteland 2 they
made a really conscious effort to keep
those chains going for a very very long
time sort of which you don't see for
many many hours into the game which i
think is is great and that point you
pretty much committed to it and married
to it which i think makes for much more
enriching reactive experience personally
so for example you could meet some
bartender called Gorgon ovitch in the
rail nomads you can buy snake squeezes
from him you can learn that they're
pretty crappy quality we don't tell the
player hey go back and talk to this guy
get pissed at him but we assume that
players would probably some players
probably want to they're like you know
what I spent money on this this guy
[ __ ] robbed me I'm gonna go back and
confront him on this even though no
one's expressly telling me to do it and
then once that happens because it makes
logical sense that she would do that
only as a player like I mean you know I
thought I was playing a D&D game I'd go
find that guy beat him up and then
having a quest sparked off of that
usually it's things that players would
logically think to do that we actually
keep the reactivity change going in some
instances and other times though
supposedly referenced the quest giver or
the specific event and
the plug is all because I did that I
understand why this is occurring you're
free to go around and beat people up
because wasteland 2 doesn't discriminate
against how you want to build your
character if you're allowing the player
to build their character a certain way
you have to respect their choices and
make sure those choices are viable
because if you give the player a bunch
of options to build a character that
ends up being overall terrible they're
having a should credibly crappy time
playing the game well then that's on the
designers side not on the players side
so what you want to do is if you're
giving the player the option to build
their character say whether there was
like a smartass a kiss-ass a hard-ass a
combat guy a stealth guy you want to
make sure there's cool things for each
of those types of characters to do and
moments were they shine or they're like
you know what because I was a smartass
in this situation I feel really good
really good that I how witted that NPC
or found that solution they're probably
very few other people would have done
because they didn't specialize in the
skill that I did and if outsmarting
people isn't your thing don't worry the
harsh environment of wasteland to
facilitate some violence in a way that
few other RPGs do sometimes what games
will do is they want to preserve all
quest givers and like make them
invulnerable so if you actually do
trying to attack them like there's no
way to kill them for example which feels
really weird especially if you do want
to be a violent character it's a very
violent world and one of the design
mandates for wasteland 2 was that you
actually you know you actually just
can't kill everybody if you want to like
so no one's really immortal or
untouchable killing everybody will have
its consequences but not in the form of
good or evil points this avoids a key
problem that Avalon experienced on
Knights of the Old Republic - it was
very difficult in dialogue situations to
try and get the player away from making
just the dark side on my side choice I
mean like in some instances they
wouldn't even care that much about the
context they would just go ok what's the
light side response here and in that
instance that feels like it's doing the
narrative disservice because the player
is not even thinking about the situation
they're involved with they're just
thinking about how do I get more light
side or dark side points wasteland
avoids that issue by going you know what
we don't have a morality system like
that you can approach each situation as
an individual and make an individual
choice for that situation
you just it's it that that is just you
role-playing that is the sitting you
want to make and there might be
consequences of doing that but and
you're able to sort of take that
situation and not worry about bad karma
good karma or you know light side dark
side it's just like you can focus in the
situations just think well what should I
do here or what do I feel like doing
they just accept the consequences
they're on so all that's left to ask
yourself is how are you going to play
wasteland 2 or perhaps more importantly
are you prepared to deal with the
consequences
[Music]